hey everybody welcome to the super craft
brothers tournament we got 16 people in
here and you will see them throughout
the game but um we're going to do a
quick intro here and i want to say hi to
everybody and we're going to split up
the groups we're going to have four mini
games cut into two parts and you guys
will be able to see it over the course
of the next few days so enjoy and here
goes the first round see you guys in a
minute
peace
enjoy people
yo guys what's up this is prestige here
mad luigi and we have oh gosh we have a
game of
as striker said we have a good ol ow ow
that hurt i was doing my intro you hit
me i think i just got these simple fish
too after me oh oh teleport away
out bad silverfish all right we're
playing super crafty bros which is kind
of like a mix of uh
super smash bros
a in minecraft
oh
strafe strafe
yeah i can't get my straightforward no
that's my kill oh gosh nope nope escape
escape escape escape yes
i have no idea what's happening right
now wow this stupid poison
yeah i'm not dead yet not dead yet not
dead yet
oh gosh no no escape
oh i have so little hearts left i've so
little hearts left so yeah guys so there
are some kits and they're random maps i
don't know if they're supposed to
emulate super mario bros maps but yeah
i'm gonna i'm gonna stay back here and
regen some
health never stop standing over there
i'm reaching some health okay so a
little rabbit a little while i'm coming
for you
oh no oh oh oh he can like fly oh he
just flew back on the map oh my gosh oh
my god
oh okay good job good job
yeah little rabbit hey someone left
myself
oh strafe
can't get can't beat my strafe boy
your stupid potions are annoying
no die die
those coaches off we're gonna
you're doing lots of explosions or is
that wither boy
oh my gosh i don't want to get in the
range of your like
potions of death
apparently i killed you my silverfish
ah i didn't even expect you yup i'm i'm
getting destroyed
i just keep hearing someone else with a
bow just like
yeah the wither bow
oh gosh
dear lord now he's spamming potions
no no no die die die die die oh bail
bail
he's going to be tactical here we need
to tell you i'm mad no no no no you
don't no you
jump um
come on guys i'm mad i'm gonna die i'm
gonna so die i have a heart no escape
escape escape
he's been sneaking away with those
stupid ender poles yeah now i can't use
another one because i'll just die if i
use it
oh well
you fell off the map
what the hell yeah okay that just killed
me okay i threw too far
oh against black i'm getting lag okay
we're good oh yeah oh yeah oh oh oh oh
crap no ah
dang it
oh i just installed two lives come on
does this have knock back yeah this is
knock back one sharpness two okay that's
why it hit you so far away
make sure make sure i win
i literally only have one life more than
you guys
killed the other kids i have none
now it's all even
no i think we should finish him first
little oh okay that's finishing first oh
you dirty you're so dirty
and if not that means me and you at
least got second place
we good with that
guy's over there oh there he is there he
is
did you not see me before
no i did not
seems like enderman class is the way to
go
yeah
[ __ ]
hey there mad
hello
oh you're your friends attacking you too
oop oh he killed you he killed you
he killed you
he he so killed you he just killed you
he usually get betrayed
let's get it yeah
stupid potions
oh gosh
oh go away go away go away
fish
we're going down together
oh oh yep there it goes we all have one
life left
get close
oh dang it doesn't work
v10
dang it
wither effects
i know they're dead annoying
wait no you're going off yep uh i think
i'm going to lose this because i'm
injured from that fight with him yes
come on
come on come on come
on let's get in my little silver fish
pets screw yourself fish i'm actually
gonna live with it probably with this
with the friggin newbies uh frigging
clashing yeah
i think i can regen health this way
silverfish yes
i think i'm regenerating health this way
oh crap that that that's not good that's
not good what is this what is this
potion of fire resistance what the uh
okay
i think it drops right that's not gonna
help you is it with me
no it's not really gonna help against
silver fish oh crap silverfish no go
away
crazy
yes all right guys hope you enjoyed that
that was first round we'll go back there
and look at the second round yeah
alright guys peace out back with round
number two this is the winner games
yeah hello
these are all the guys we got first on
the last one so it should be a very epic
game it kind of scared me a little bit i
almost fell i thought this oh this map
oh oh oh oh you can like fall off this
map you can like fall off this map easy
oh gosh i know i i don't like this map i
don't like it
i love it
god that's so much damage
damn it i still died i killed myself
i'm not good with the creeper i don't
know why i chose this one holy [ __ ]
okay i made that jump
all right
okay i won last game but this is more of
what i usually do oh my gosh
i want to be on a place where i don't
have to like just i don't just die like
an area where i just don't just die
okay hopefully i don't get just killed
going up here again
i'm not gonna i'm trying to run away i'm
sorry i won't spawn camp you
what the hell damn i just saw you
killing myself i just drink the milk on
my way down
okay so i just placed jeb's call on the
ground it just does nothing it pushes
other players away when you're next to
him
it didn't
i didn't use i didn't use the last time
what it was so now i just can
i'm really confused oh someone's
shooting arrows at me
escape escape escape escape
what what class is that that has that
like super knock back arrow uh i'm not
telling you that's an annoying class oh
my gosh
oh leo has one life so i think we need
to kill agent lampert
oh no no no
kill kill agent kill where where's asian
that agent is over there agents over
there i see you agent
i know they're close to me
i see agent
be in my corner who's gonna help me
attack agent
i feel like you're gonna win this round
christian
what just cause you
you're a camper i'm not i'll kill oh oh
gosh what the i said go for agent
lambert not me
well he's out of my range oh and i'm in
your range of course yeah of course
this is how i like just killed
everybody's range and
aim at him you're the one with long
range attacks
i have a sword
i don't know if i can make that jump it
sucks
oh here's one life oh oh oh well
we need we need to kill big boy
this is probably not a safe place for me
to be at all we all need to kill
christian yeah
i probably can't make that jump
i don't know i got the same amount of
lives that you guys got together it's
the only the only fair thing to do is to
kill him shut up christmas oh you got
him
oh yeah can i make that jump
okay this actually hurts
thorns your little ball sack
it's not cheating it's
winning
cheater
down hello aj
fight me
someone just killed christian please oh
what don't hit me oh my gosh he he just
hits oh what the what
what what what what oh your sister spawn
camping me okay okay no i was i was
actually camping myself okay kill anyone
else
so do i just place this down once and it
hits everyone away i'm confused on what
this does
you you push it you put it on the ground
and it's supposed to push anybody within
like a three or four block radius dad
did nothing oh my gosh oh my gosh why is
your sword op by the way oh i finally
killed him i finally killed him after
like three tries
with his mr
op sword oh leo
what what class do you have where you
just insta kill us oh cactus
i'm using cactus next round
okay well no that's gaming now i can't
get out of this car guys i have to stay
in this call because i'm hosting it so
oh
and that's one more
christian's gonna win this one all right
guys
hope you enjoyed that
i hope you enjoyed that second game that
that was terrible oh my god
hey you beat me oh that's true
oh i i i my final death was me failing a
jump oh that was my first two deaths
okay all right so guys i'll catch you in
the third game peace out